Back around the turn of the last century, the average farmer could feed six or eight people.
Now, the average American farmer can feed 126 people, okay?
These are the most productive humans that have ever lived.
The changes down on the farm have been momentous...
...and radical, but invisible to most of us 'cause who knows a farmer anymore.
But their way of life has been revolutionized.
10,000 years ago, farmers started saving the best seeds and planting again in the following year.
That's how seeds have been developed. That's how corn was developed from...
...a useless grass for the most part to the extremely productive plant than it is today.
The idea that any corporation could own a food crop, you know, is a very new idea.
And it wasn't until the 1980s that the Supreme Court said, "You could patent life."
And that opened the floodgates, efforts to patent the most valuable parts of life,...
...which is to say the crops on which we depend.
Monsanto was a chemical company.
They produced DDT, Agent Orange in Vietnam, and then they developed a product called "Roundup."
We started hearing rumblings about genetically - engineered soybeans...
...that could resist the application of Roundup.
When the Roundup was sprayed over the top of it, it killed every weed out there...
...except for this Roundup Ready soybean.
I can remember when the first prohibition against seed saving came into being.
Most farmers were just absolutely disgusted with the whole concept.
And it's been interesting over the course of 11 years to watch us go from...
...utter contempt for the notion that we can't save our own seed to acceptance.